[Musica]
poi sono stata invitata a parlare di
bellezza che è un tema complesso e
affascinante mi è venuta in mente una
citazione una citazione di dostoevskij
che scriveva in demoni l'umanità non può
vivere senza la bellezza l'umanità senza
bellezza non ha motivo di esistere
e questa una citazione che da ragazzo mi
ha sempre colpito e mi ha fatto venire
fuori una domanda la domanda che è ma
perché sentiamo l'esigenza di vivere in
spazi belli di circondarsi di cose belle
non di vivere esperienze belle non
bastano semplicemente non basta
semplicemente che ci siano e quindi che
cos'è quell'inutile cesso no che
chiediamo al mondo
questa è la domanda no con cui vorrei
discutere conversare con voi in questi
pochi minuti parto da una riflessione
che sono un'imprenditrice insieme alla
mia famiglia sono ancona designer sono
progettiste dei servizi e mi rendo conto
che tutti i giorni
viviamo in una società e una
contemporaneità che ci abbraccia con il
desiderio di proporci soluzioni
esperienze che funzionino viviamo questa
promessa del vivere esperienze stabili
che funzionano
il vero problema è che ci stiamo
educando ad un'unica visione sempre più
a una visione funzionale e quindi ci
stiamo abituando a non riconoscere nella
diversità di quello che viviamo nei
servizi negli ambienti nelle creatività
in quello che progettiamo e quindi il
problema che spesso rischiamo no di
livellare le aspettative ci stiamo
abituando ci stiamo educando un
livellamento complessivo quest'anno
preoccupazione che ho come imprenditrice
come collega ma anche come mamma e
quindi il rischio che io vedo
ed è un rischio che tutti i giorni col
quale lotto è quello di no non
standardizzare di non produrre
esperienze spazi servizi oggetti
situazioni che rischiano di essere
standardizzate per assicurare che
funzionino per assicurare con la
promessa di stabilità e quindi il
rischio è spesso a incorrere una
banalizzazione una omogeneizzazione è
questo che cosa s visto che la bellezza
gli interventi di prima non ce l'hanno
raccontato bene ha un patrimonio comune
il rischio che ci impoveriamo tutti
allora dostoevskij è una citazione
perché è interessante perché è
innovativa perché ci dice tre cose la
prima che la bellezza è un bisogno
primario
noi siamo abituati a considerare il
bisogno il mangiare il dormire ma la
bellezza e ha un bisogno che ci aiuta
non solo a sopravvivere ma a vivere
quindi è un bisogno è un incontro che
cambia le cose
un incontro precedente la parola
incontro è stata ricorsiva quindi un
incontro la capacità di costruire no una
corrispondenza che scatena qualcosa
il secondo aspetto interessante che
dostoevskij nella sua citazione mia mi
ha fatto riflettere è che la bellezza
muove
cosa vuol dire che nella sua frase che
dice no l'uomo non potrebbe vivere senza
la bellezza vuol dire che la bellezza
diventa movente che cos'è un movente
quello che scatena desiderio è quello
che ci chiede tutte le volte ci convoca
per progettare per creare no perché è
quindi la bellezza genera progetti e
progetti non ci trasformano e
trasformano quindi se la prima
riflessione che la bellezza è un bisogno
e la seconda che ha un movente la terza
che quindi è un'esperienza è
un'esperienza di che cosa
e l'esperienza di uno spiazzamento lo
spiazzamento che cos'è quando lo
incontriamo qualcosa che bello che no
che ci parla
vedete che le persone si sofferma
capiscono che c'è quell eccesso inutile
che devono capire e quindi che cosa
succede una magia un'alchimia le persone
si predispongono a comportamenti
positivi quindi quando la bellezza
spiazza quando la bellezza incontra le
persone che si ha davanti a un'opera che
si ha davanti un libro che sia una
situazione che sia la musica che sia uno
scorcio di una città che sia un ambiente
in realtà la magia che sottende a questo
incontro è che le persone liberano
comportamenti positivi fanno accadere
l'immaginazione liberano energia e
quindi questo è quello che noi
tecnicamente quando parliamo noi coi
nostri colleghi spesso non lo definiamo
il design del 2 turno quindi quella
capacità di innestare di innescare
un'esperienza positiva che mette le
persone in uno stato di ascolto e anche
quando hanno poco tempo e quando una
vita no frettolosa impone ritmi
accelerati
quando succede qualcosa di bello le
persone si predispongono quindi io vi
farò vedere delle immagini che non sono
patinato non sono belle ma sono dei
tentativi che tutti i giorni noi
facciamo quindi no
proviamo ad accompagnare i processi di
trasformazione dove la trasformazione è
data se riusciamo a portare a bordo le
persone e quindi proviamo a costruire
questi innesti non sempre ci riusciamo
e molto difficile ma quando succede che
riusciamo a costruire quell'incontro si
scatenano delle magie delle alchimie di
oporto nei miei ricordi e che mi
rafforzano tutti i giorni come impegno e
quindi quando dobbiamo insegnare le
persone alla collaborazione che sono i
nostri uffici
quindi noi costruiamo magari delle
situazioni particolari o diverse o
quando o quando dobbiamo trasferire
anche contenuti complessi che magari le
persone capiscono che c'è quell'inutile
eccesso che non capiscono e quindi si
soffermano
però partecipano condividano ogni anno
costruiamo degli appuntamenti con oltre
12 13 mila persone anche solo in una
settimana
noi ci regalano ci regalano le loro idee
e la loro creatività
oppure quando portiamo non so viviamo e
lavoriamo in una periferia non di
lambrate
abbiamo portato i bambini del quartiere
a vedere il museo museo importante di
milano s'è scatenato un incontro con la
bellezza di stupore che ha costruito no
ha portato ci ha portato i luoghi
diversi
i nostri stessi uffici o la capacità
tutte le volte che costruiamo degli
strumenti di lavoro di lavorare con
quella estetica che aiuta a raccontare
che aiuta a spiegare che aiuta a
ingaggiare le persone e quindi anche un
progetto no come wii com che un progetto
open source diventa una palestra per
sperimentare dei linguaggi quindi la
bellezza anche un linguaggio è un
linguaggio che ci invita perché cose
belle ci parlano molto più delle altre è
una sintassi che non è solo fatta di
parole è una sfida è molto difficile ma
un impegno che noi dobbiamo avere
perché una cosa l'ho imparata ho
imparato proprio come imprenditrice e
l'ho imparata anche come persona che
crede moltissimo nelle persone e che se
noi vogliamo che la bellezza deve essere
negli occhi di chi guarda soprattutto la
bellezza deve essere nei nostri occhi e
quindi noi dobbiamo allenare educare noi
in primis ripensarci aiutare i nostri
figli avere delle prospettive diverse
educarli alla bellezza come educare
inoltre le persone col quale lavoriamo
insieme perché solo così noi riusciremo
a portare con la bellezza che dice
dostoevskij è il sale della vita grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]